hi there Steve Kaufman I want to talk
today about how we find the time to
learn languages I think this is a very
important question thank you to the
person who asked me this question here
at my youtube channel I often hear
people say I would like to learn Spanish
or French but I don't have the time well
first of all if it's important enough to
you you will find the time because we do
find the time to do things that are
important but but there is a legitimate
concern that if a person is totally
wrapped up in language earning they can
become like Hermits for the other
members of their family so what can we
do well first of all I think the the
first thing and I should mention that I
posted on this subject of my blog the
linguist on language the first thing is
to recognize that that if you can train
yourself to devote most of your learning
time to listening just plain listening
then you can create all kinds of time
for language learning and I mean 80
percent of my language learning time is
spent just listening and there's a
reason for that the reason is that I can
create at least an hour of time every
day when I am going to and from work
when I'm doing the dishes when I'm doing
chores I'm sitting and waiting standing
in line I always have a listening device
with me and the listening devices today
I mean I happen to have a range but here
you have this little iPod shuffle I
don't know what it costs 30 40 50
dollars but there are mp3 players that
cost five or ten dollars so everyone
should be able to afford an mp3 player
now if you want to become more
sophisticated of course you can go to
the iPod Nano or I happen to also have
an iPod Touch pardon the glare but these
devices are yeah they're a little
expensive but they're an investment a
tremendous investment far more powerful
to my mind a combination of this little
device and the internet and iTunes is
more powerful than any language lab that
put into schools for the cost of twenty
thirty thousand dollars
tremendously powerful well worth the
investment so but you have to and of
course in terms of not becoming a hermit
around the house my wife doesn't mind I
should say by the way that we should
also invest in good quality listening
devices so I have you know this looks
like a mess of spaghetti here but but
they hang on my earlobe so they don't
fall out the sound quality is very good
and that's extremely important because
when we're learning a foreign language
need to hear well and I have a strategy
in my listening like when I start I
listen to the same content over and over
again and as long as the brain is being
challenged it it will stay focused so if
for example you're listening and it's 5%
comprehensible it's just too much for
the brain in my opinion so it's hard to
focus but if you're 60% comprehensible
input and there's always the same part
that you can't get then you're kind of
motivated to keep listening and I in the
beginning of this and often to the same
content and combine it with reading and
combine it with saving words and phrases
from the text that I'm reading so I'm
working a little bit with the computer
but then I mostly go on and listen and
listen to listen gradually as I get
better I don't listen too often and then
of course eventually graduate where I'm
listening purely for pleasure where you
can listen to audiobooks like this and
French or Italian I just grabbed a
couple of examples that were nearby and
of course the audiobooks you can convert
them through YouTube iTunes into content
that you carry around with you on your
little iPod shuffle or similar device so
listening and my wife is very happy
because I do the dishes I do chores I
don't complain because I'm happy to do
them it's an opportunity to listen so
80% listening you can learn languages
without becoming a hermit be careful
that you don't wander around with your
earphones on while your wife is talking
to you she may not go for it or your
husband whatever the case may be partner
second thing is we all have time to read
we don't spend the whole day
our partners and yes we have obligations
social family professional and so forth
and so on but we do have time to read so
get in the habit of reading in the
target language now that may initially
be reading simple books that teach
yourself series or whatever it might be
eventually you graduate from that but
but I
and also another thing that I find
useful is I always leave a grammar book
like and a grammar books the smaller the
grammar book the better and I leave one
of these are in Spanish I happen to find
out whatever I had handy here I have
similar small grammar books for the
various time we just leave them by your
toilet sorry to be vulgar but the
grammar is something you want to leave
through from time to time or if you're
gonna be sitting in a doctor's office or
something waiting take a little grammar
book with you you can always leave
through the grammar book and sometimes
you pick things up that that are helpful
but there again eventually you graduate
to things of interest you know this is
an Italian K ledger a class C Qi you
know I was in Portugal Coleman is not
say before to go I even found this thing
and this is the kind of stuff you can
find out there here is for Portuguese
Fernando Pessoa and it's a list of or at
least a collection of some of the things
that he has said including pop including
poetry and it includes a CD which I can
put in and then convert to my mp3 player
we had a great go add linguistics here
at the youth my youtube channel and when
I was in France I got a business one of
the books that I got little gosh not to
use to I use odd that aoki language
deeply their bodies your Jean Lazare
sure so you can get into a subject of
interest but do it in the target
language or in the case of Italian here
what we got here Cocteau Amanjit or D
Chet is called a true key de menu lots
of stuff on cooking in Italian I mean I
have a few minutes I can read a recipe
all of this is language is exposure
exposure to things that are of interest
so if you can somehow move your language
running away from something that's
structured into something that's
enjoyable
then you're more likely to find the time
and also you can then fit it in when
you've got five minutes here ten minutes
there at my blog I posted three links to
because I sort of in researching this
video
I googled finding the time and to learn
languages and I found three articles
which you can read on my blog but
personally most of the advice I would
say most but some of the advice that
they offer there to my mind is a little
complicated like I'm as I said before
shadowing is not something that I find
that I can continue doing you know so I
think there's suggesting that you
transcribe everything you hear I'm sure
these things are great and if you do
them great but if I walk around the
house shadowing you know I think that
again is starting to get a little hermit
II I I find I haven't got the dedicated
time so that I mostly listen then I go
to my computer to do a little bit of
linking to get a handle on some of the
new words and phrases but then mostly I
I listened and reached I'm doing sort of
normal pleasurable activities I don't
worry about the fact that I don't have a
chance to speak I try to speak as much
as I can at linked with our tutors but I
can't spend the day speaking it's a
little more difficult to organize the
speaking whereas if I've got five
minutes I can just listen or if I'm
going to go for a run I can just listen
or if I have ten minutes I sit down and
I can leave through a grammar book or if
I'm enjoying a novel like the other day
or the other earlier in the year when we
were in Spain visiting in Segovia and
Madrid then I read a novel that I bought
locally called La Casa de Lucia avocados
so that I'd like to do things that are
enjoyable that he's been going so I'm
really converting some of my leisure
time into language learning time and so
then essentially to my mind it all comes
down to what do you think is important
if you think it is important to learn
languages or the language you're working
on you will find the time and especially
if the activities
that you are engaged in our largely
enjoyable activities all the more so so
that what is the French expression you
want on duty at Leggett I AB so you're
doing things that are both useful and
agreeable and hopefully not in such a
way that you are disrupting your other
family social and professional
relationships okay thank you for
listening bye for now